through the end of this year obviously i
think most of the data that you uh post
on twitter or talk about shows that
we're still in a bull market what's your
kind of price thoughts or price
predictions for the end of 2021
yeah um i think you know something i'm
watching closely is the evergrand thing
um you know there's been a lot of talk
about that recently on twitter but um
there's there's potential for there you
know kind of be some sort of spillover
contagion effects um with that but
ultimately the supply dynamics i mean i
do talk with with will every day and i'm
looking at that same data um it's
extremely bullish like you know the most
bullish i've ever been um and so you
know these supply dynamics it doesn't
lie and a lot of times derivatives will
whip saw price back and forth but i
think ultimately um we're i'm pretty
confident in all-time highs breaking by
2021 and at that point it's off to the
races bitcoin trades reflexively um you
know once all-time highs are broken or
um you know essentially people just stop
selling price gets gets bid
uh really hard at the margin and you're
gonna have a ton of new capital kind of
flowing in um there's a lot of talk
behind the scenes of big money um you
know buying buying in this range and so
you know i think that's only gonna you
know kind of pick up from here and i
think you know once 60 64k 65k is broken
it's off to the races and so you know
i'm pretty confident in that occurring
uh in 2021 um and you know depending on
how fast a rip to 100k is is in the
carts um and so price predictions are
kind of hard but you know supply
dynamics are extremely bullish and
especially if china or you know the fed
broadly kind of respond to any sort of
credit contagion or you know anything
happening in the legacy markets you know
that's just rocket fuel for bitcoin and
when you think about this are you a
subscriber to this like super cycle
theory that once we break the all-time
high we go up you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars or is it something
where uh maybe will is in more of the
thought process of like 180 185 000
based on some of the models he's looking
at like how severe is that reflexivity
once we break the all-time highs in your
opinion
yeah i mean i i'm a little in both camps
so i mean one is like i'm just going to
be looking at the data but i think
there's a real chance and i don't know
if it happens in 2022 or 2024 but at
some point um bitcoin success
is going to just be so so obvious and
the narrative is not going to be between
you know with us just kind of niche uh
you know econ nerds or you know um
hardcore bitcoiners like libertarian
kind of thing i think that's even
shifted recently but um it's gonna be oh
my god the legacy financial world it's
like you know i'm sitting on a trillion
dollar bond tranche and i'm getting i'm
getting a negative yield right like
these guys that are basically still
locked in these they can't get bitcoin
exposure yet um but if an etf comes as
it just gets more mainstreamed
intertwined with you know the legacy
system companies like naidig and all
this you know they're they're gonna
unlock trillions and trillions of
dollars capital to access the bitcoin
markets and and the you know the most
bullish aspect is that when you're
looking at a liquid supply when you're
just looking at the free flow of this
thing that that's trading every single
day you know about 14 15 million bitcoin
aren't available to be sold and like
people like me like i'm not like i don't
have a 20 200 000 price target where i'm
selling my all my bitcoin i'm just like
i might you know sell a few basis points
or you know like you know obviously
money's you know meant to be spent but
the the reality is like my price target
for bitcoin is infinity like i don't
plan on i'll spend bitcoin when when uh
you know it's legal tender and i don't
pay taxes on it
and so like you know i think that's
that's the reality here and you're gonna
have tens of trillions of dollars
chasing um you know a few million
bitcoin and so you know do the math on
that but ultimately um i think at some
point over the next five to ten years
maybe i don't i don't think it gets that
far the dollar price becomes somewhat
irrelevant um as trust is lost um we've
just we've just pushed you know they've
kicked the can so so far um and you know
what happens next time the legacy
markets crash well the feds the feds use
all its ammo and it's gonna just you
know it's gonna it's gonna they're gonna
blow the load again and it's it's gonna
get i think it's gonna get kind of crazy
so um you know super cycle not not
entirely sure i think you know naturally
there's going to be boom and busts um 50
drawdowns are here to stay especially
with how over-indebted the the legacy
system is right um you know you're going
to see these these huge cascades just
because of how how much debt is in the
system um and then how much impairment
that causes with you know with with the
legacy system fiat money uh money's
created through lending but it's also
destroyed through debt uh debt default
right so so when that happens you're
going to see just massive drawdowns and
equities real estate bitcoin like um
that's just where we are in the you know
in the system and so they're gonna have
to reinflate it all and that's you know
that's when bitcoin trades to seven
figures
i uh i tend to think that you're more
right than wrong here what's up guys
bang bang thanks so much for watching
the best business show today if we're
gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]